6 23 on a thursday morning we're here in
the eight news now kitchen but you don't
have to spend time in the kitchen when
it's las vegas restaurant week you
should be going out and having some good
times there are so many incredible
restaurants in the valley no shortage of
good food you know that but the key is
that not only are you getting good food
but you're giving to a good cause brian
burton joining us from three square and
that's where the donations go and what
an incredible venture for you guys to be
able to participate with all these
amazing restaurants well we love it we
think this is the largest most diverse
showcasing of the culinary community of
the year for for las vegas and i as you
said almost 200 restaurants you get
value meals
and knowing that that meal that you're
eating will provide up to 18 meals for
our neighbors in need does it get any
better than that no it's fantastic
sample so many great restaurants around
town i've been to the sushi restaurant
over at caesar's palace in the forum
shops
so many great things but we should also
talk about you know the need obviously
it's a it's a great event but the need
hasn't really gone away during the
pandemic you guys were slammed uh hasn't
gone away what what is the demand right
now with tim square john that's what's
sobering as we're seeing a spike in
demand lately i mean of course when the
shutdown happened and a third of our
community was unemployed we were in
direct service on the front lines with
lines four miles deep with cars of
people needing help
but now it's people facing inflation
with food and gas prices out of sight
their rents have gone up so much the
working poor are being squeezed so these
are not folks that don't want to work or
i mean they are working they're working
several jobs most of them raising their
kids doing the best they can but what's
great about restaurant week is we can
provide a little bit of relief it raises
about a quarter million dollars wow and
so that's almost uh
three-quarters of a million meals
so we have very efficient
almost no overhead 96 cents of every
dollar goes directly into programs so i
just want to encourage people between
now and the 17th go to
restaurantweeklv.org find one of your
favorite restaurants off the strip if
you're a local don't want to go on the
strip
you can go anywhere
a value price between
dollars you're gonna get several courses
yum yum and just knowing that you know
in your heart you're doing something
very special for our community and
there's some incredible ones i know we
had kind of teased that sdk was going to
be here and it's live tv things happen
but it is these incredible restaurants
here in town that are showcasing the
best of and stk is one of my favorite
places
is one of the best people i've met since
i've been here so but we have we have
great partners i mean this community is
like none other yeah and the generosity
and three square being the backbone of
the charitable food distribution we get
to see
we have a front row seat on 185
charities every day that depend on us to
bring in the food from california and
this is nutritious wonderful food this
is not food that you don't want to eat
and so we just love getting to do what
we do
hunger is a solvable problem come to
restaurant week through now through from
now through the 17th and enjoy a nice
meal and help other people absolutely
it's a great we have all the details on
eightnewsnow.com as well uh take part if
you can't all go through such a great
housing restaurants taking part brian
burton from three square thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate it
appreciate your time this morning